hello and welcome to this video playing
Tom k91 let's see what we get here
against Tom came g6 okay we don't know
yet if he wants a green felt working
zinnia he wants a green felt okay let's
play h4 funny line h5 Wow
I didn't know that this is actually line
maybe Bishop g5 would have been
interesting there anyway so we have a
normal looking guru felt but with h4 h5
inserted yeah I have no clue who died
who that may favor no idea moe
maybe black kind of making things up
here really okay so it's that right so
if I move the rook now I'm threatening
d5 at least me not not threatening in
the sense of that it wins but
strategically I can I can play that more
at least
yeah that looks very normal yeah here I
would actually it's tough to say I
wanted to say I would suspect that this
is rather favorable insertion of more
Samia but stuff it's really it's really
tough to say
h4 h5 I mean that this is favorable for
me let's see what he does now g4 I might
simply take and play h5 that could be
dangerous he calls back yeah in this
particular case there is f5 which is
also something that could be an issue
it's very very direct down
I'm a management that should be good
right okay so now do I go Bishop d2 or
King f1 I'm thinking everyone I have to
say Bishop b2 is a temple Queen a - but
he's threatening Queen a1 immediately
then which she does anyway that's a bit
of a pain okay so we get let's go here I
am Not sure that Queen takes a - is a
good move
however this one really Wow
I did not think that this is good so we
should age six or rook g1 what is he
actually playing against Bishop h6 if it
takes a true team one will kill them and
I'm threatening what do you wanted
everything okay so show me Knight f6
erskine g5
[Music]
quencher 598 said somehow holding I
would be it would be odd Oh interesting
yeah I don't think he would have enough
for the exchange but still is there
anything better
I don't think so let's take this I can
insert the check here
oh yeah it's probably helpful now take
this and the question is do I take f5 as
well on the pawn structure is really
really bad but this this is actually
good right that makes this night look
rather rather bad
hmm didn't think that this was possible
I see really escaping this check check
No
no I cannot
I've got no time should be a bit quicker
I mean I thought I might have a mate day
out but I didn't see it but if you just
just win like that it's it's fine
I guess so how do we win
let me check do we hate or something
okay
mmm gambling winning now him
okay so what what's interesting if I'm
not really totally certain about the
whole opening him this age for line is
interesting some it's it looks a little
bit it looks a little bit unsound
somehow they're pushing the edge Palmer
but it is quite quite interesting
okay so h5 and yam seed if I maybe this
is good yeah it's it's interesting the
the point is that typical response there
is this but that doesn't work because I
can take here and I'm just a pawn up I
can actually take c3 okay it's sit
interesting probably this is better than
taking so okay we had this and c5 Jim
maybes maybe Bishop g4 at some point is
an idea where h4 and h5 inserted matches
so I mean I don't think he did anything
wrong there either need to be clear on
that I think he only later made a
mistake
so castles looks he won and now he went
Bishop g4 yeah but I don't know this set
I mean here I felt I should be fine
really
I mean finding meaning I better this
insertion here with FY 5 looks dangerous
relief for black so he played rook c8
Mangin just wants to Castle okay okay so
f4 was my choice and this yeah I really
suspected this must be the critical move
I would have taken an played h5 that was
my idea at least and
the engine doesn't even mention this
idea how is it really know now the
evaluation goes up at least a little bit
so check I thought I can always go he
and it should be dangerous here with the
age file opening up this seems to be a
defense the O'Quinn be one yeah yeah
that's an interesting position I mean
black seems to be in the game at least
yeah 97 ok f5 was the brutal way to do
it and I suspect that you cannot take on
a 5 there I think this should lose yeah
Bishop h6 and Russia won both win you
know Russia one is the alternative seems
to be even better but yeah I mean
threatening too much this I just wanted
to check i look look g1 is actually even
stronger
I was I was intending to play this but I
wasn't sure if I'm immediately winning
after Quincy 3 but it seems that this is
good enough yeah a black epic ass no
more names but this is also strong
because 94 Queen g5 is or even taking us
but I am ok and then this is just queen
bee tube or something you going to be to
f6 d6
okay what I did is also fine it should
should win I'm fairly certain had had
some some maids but or winning a piece I
don't know it looked a lot like that but
you can so Luke g6 stronger well I mean
I didn't have that much time and I
needed some easy to handle solutions
I'm just taking all the courses it's
kind of it's right it's enough yeah so I
don't think I don't think it's much to
look at after that h4 is an interesting
line in fact I think that best seems to
be c6 nowadays and gap gives it a bit of
a weird look it looks like sloth somehow
and then h4 is somehow played it's it's
odd very interesting to play thanks a
lot for watching